&gt;&gt; Here my inputs are 4, 1, 4 and 5. So I list this here. I don't need to list
this 4 twice so I'm going to erase this one. My outputs are 3, 2, 5 and negative
1. I draw my arrows to represent the ordered pairs. 4 is with 3, 1 is with 2, 4
is with 5, and 5 is with negative 1. Notice that I have an input leading to two
outputs. So this first one is definitely not a function. We can see this more
easily because the input repeats. If the input repeats, then that means it
produces two different outputs which we know can't be true. So, if we have one
x-value producing two different y-values, we know it's not a function. Here's a
mapping diagram for the second set. The arrows indicate the ordered pairs, and I
see that each input corresponds to exactly one output. So yes, this is a
function.